so after notching some wins last week
the failed former president donald trump
has a pretty serious endorsement failure
on his hands now as the alleged serial
groper
charles herbster has suffered a primary
defeat although trump did get a win in
west virginia last night so we're going
to talk about it as well as the
implications the big news of course
trump backed herbster accused of groping
loses to pillon in nebraska that was the
nebraska gubernatorial mooney wins in
west virginia the mixed results for
trump came in contests pitting him
against local republican leaders as a
reminder here is donald trump talking
about uh the great charles herbster a
crew accused of groping at least eight
women
[Music]
[Applause]
the audio at that event clearly run by
antifa as you can tell but we could tell
what trump was saying which is he is
endorsing herbster and herbster is good
and herbster is going to win
but sadly for him
herbster lost the results are that jim
pillin has won the republican primary
in nebraska for the gubernatorial race
jim pillin it was close it was close
basically 34 to 30
um with a third candidate brett
lindstrom coming in at roughly 26
with just the omaha area um so that is a
defeat for donald trump uh what are the
takeaways well interesting article from
the new york times one takeaway is trump
still did get a win in west virginia on
paper west virginia's new second
congressional district should have given
an advantage to mckinley who previously
represented a larger area seeking a
seventh term
but mooney 50 years old who once led the
republican party in neighboring maryland
romped across nearly the entire district
trump's endorsement is widely seen as
powering the mooney campaign in one of
the states where the former president
has been more pop most popular
trump also referring to mckinley as a
i'm sorry mooney referring to mckinley
as a rhino which has been a popular
attack
for uh donald trump so so far this
primary season
you know the the j.r majewski thing is
complicated because j.r majewski pledged
loyalty to trump he was on his knees for
trump praying at the altar of trump but
trump didn't actually endorse majewski
but after majewski won trump said like
hey i didn't even really know about this
guy but he's a trump guy and he's great
uh so now sort of like an endorsement
going into the general but listen
trump's record so far is pretty good 75
roughly depending on how you calculate
it and the reason we care about this is
not so much because trump claims he has
a perfect endorsement record when it's
really a pretty average endorsement
record over the last five years that's
not actually why we care about this we
care about this because we know
that among whether trump is in a lot of
legal trouble and whether trump has
health problems that another factor that
will influence whether trump tries to
run again in 2024 is whether he
perceives that he can easily win at
minimum the republican nomination if not
the general
and one of the ways that he and we and
others will be able to ascertain whether
he's got a shot at the republican
nomination at minimum is whether his
endorsement continues to carry
significant weight in the 2022 midterms
and so far it's certainly carrying some
weight in fact i would even venture to
say it's very early but so far
trump's record in 2022
is better than his overall record over
the last few years it's very early we
have only a handful of races and over
the next month and really over the next
yeah roughly the next four or five weeks
we're going to have a number of
additional primaries trump putting out a
series of endorsements yesterday on his
website and many of them are incumbents
so you know when
is it really a big win
if you endorse an incumbent and the
incumbent wins i would argue no but all
of it is what can you justify
what can you convince your followers of
and so far trump is doing okay although
i mean listen
going with the eight times accused
serial groper
in uh nebraska
maybe it was destined not to go
particularly well now later we're going
to talk about elon musk saying that if
he finishes his purchase of twitter
he would unban donald trump from the
platform i'll give my thoughts on that
later
merely anecdotally
i kind of would love to see what trump
would be tweeting about his herbster
endorsement right now if he were on
twitter
he would probably be saying something
like were it not for the fake phony
fraudulent allegations of groping
i would have gotten the endorsement win
but the left made it up and
you know something like that that's my
guess of what trump would be saying
about this race if he were on twitter
but
it's good that herbster lost herbster's
a disaster
and the fact that it's a loss for trump
just makes it a little bit better
one of our long time sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style undeniable quality and
total versatility put vincero really at
the top of the game and their newest
watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far
vincero sunglasses and jewelry and other
accessories are awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to vincero collective
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below